some with potting up hello David good to
see you again I know we had a nice talk
no good to see buddy I did I have to
tell you I woke up in a panic
comics neuroses I said man what are we
going to talk about today oh we could
talk about anything we just talked to my
brain of all this knowledge yesterday we
said dick row we talked a lot of all you
have secret he did unfiltered yesterday
witch doctor Mme um so I wanted to ask
you to start with prepared your first I
was fascinated to read that you were
actually you didn't NPR radio adoption
of Star Wars I did we'll wait so my
acting teacher at Yale at the Drama
School was John Madden and he's English
he taught Shakespeare and he also
directed Shakespeare in Love but after
our first year John goes like David you
know you're going to be in LA he was
directing a radio serialized version of
Star Wars and he said call me up and
I'll hire you so I did about five days
and I got $800 and when I tell you that
was long money yeah $800 I was like oh
[ __ ] I'll do this man
so it was nice that's how we did it what
did you play stormtrooper stuff who goes
oh haha seriously that's a hundred - a
man more importantly I hung out with
like Mark Hamill and the guy who played
I think the things Anthony Daniels he
plays video and Threepio when they took
the original actors from the movie and
made a radio vert why don't they most of
them when days take the audio from the
movie that's right oh no you know why
because they said the the point of the
exercise was they wanted to serialize it
and make it like an old type radio show
so they had to break it up in there you
know this whole thing
oh okay so they did who couldn't they
get did they get your heroes on board
there's nothing
yeah the James Earl Jones did it
Harrison would be busier today she won't
know the new it right there yo kiss my
ass NPR no wow I don't know he just
wasn't there David hacker oi was the
actor and I remember this because
he had a brand-new BMW and I was like
Nazis know how to make these [ __ ] car
gave me ride home - was this furnished
apartment I lived in I forget man up
there every pilot season [ __ ] oh yeah
but I wasn't really a tracker in earlier
because you know I lived in New York at
the time and one of the first things I
noticed when they came on to LA was the
cars are cleaning this [ __ ] and they're
brand new you know New York is all
blessed it was back then people who
owned cars yeah in New York they were
always all rusted out three different
color yeah
different colored panels it was a garage
kept in LA a lot of times they're nice
in New York you gotta move it every
other day just a nightmare I park in a
garage I would never have a car here and
park in the street I will call you it's
another Harmon yeah another apartment
also in LA that's like your shoes I mean
people judge you by your car you know
and it's like wearing a suit you gotta
have you should set up yeah but there's
no I mean the weather's always good
there's no rain damage on the car
there's nothing driving around on a
sunny day I love it when I live in New
York I love the New York the thing I
loved about New York is I hate to be
like get off my lawn old dude but first
of all a lot more the cab drivers owned
their own rigs
that's a different experience as opposed
to a dude who just got here with GPS I
literally was in a cab going down sixth
Avenue and I said take me to time-worn
he goes just a minute I don't keep
driving oh my god that's right turn the
[ __ ] off that's right he said well I
don't know you're going I said we're
gonna make you stop what I said to park
man I can't drive a purser haha
seriously no they yank know where they
were going
now the point I'm trying to make is I
rode my bicycle all around the city I
would see everybody I knew you know
going on calls you talk on the street
corner and it was very communal I mean I
could get everything done within two
blocks
clothes we lick the food everything
la is different man and and now in New
York I was in a cab or two dude tried to
run over the bicycle so it was these
more than four times I'm going to give
him the question he was right I totally
agree with them by the way I think Ling
Ling and David is promoting to assist a
new show on the game trend network it
started last night or tonight actually
is you can see it again it started last
night on Monday
it's called snap decision and Tuesday's
is going to be the new the new night for
it and there's four back-to-back
episodes for so it's going to move into
its normal time slot tonight again with
another new episode so check it out
tonight we talked yesterday about it's
about judging people when you see them
how many things can you actually make a
judge about a person by watching a quick
video on the moment or buy money for
money yeah it doesn't take a lot you
offer five dollars in this leg this man
is a pedalo they go right for like
there's a young black dude who was going
that red that man is a criminal I was
like using my black brother of color
don't we suffer the same fate
shouldn't you be more in lightness in
hell no I'm trying to win this money
there has to be some that are like that
you're going to be totally wrong you
know what I mean you're going to see the
only answer in the criminal a red
herring but are there any that are just
totally accurate just to kind of laughs
of course you're good so yes of course
and you know I don't I mean I'm wrong
I'm we play the game in real time you
know I do dog the Contessa that's my
only fun I mean it's just like going
yeah house done about you know what they
I was wrong about you I cannot be
anyone's son nothing everything you say
as well you know it's fun that way but
I'm not it's not always right I don't
I'm personal my whole judgment is [ __ ]
up
I mean I'm wrong about ever special E
like in the business what movies gonna
make it ha ha ha I can't money I'm
always wrong
you've been made gonna be a hit yeah
that's the bomb you made a bad call
oh yeah the plenary closing bet she was
does menstrual blood paintings it killed
children all right you're not gonna yeah
what movie was that were you most wrong
about like what movie did you sit there
and go like this my friend this is Autry
yeah the premiere of um Jim Carrey's
movie what was it it was it was a
into a mask No Ace Ventura presenter and
so I get to the premiere and publicist
his publicist says look I sent you next
to Jimmy I was like where you know you
guys are friends and I was like okay I
sat next to Jim and he was crawling out
of his skin he was so nervous I mean
just literally crawling out of his skin
I felt so freaked out and bad for him I
said well I'm gonna buttress him it's my
boy so I laughed at everything was like
credit but inside I was like Jim's too
crazy America is not ready for this I
saw Chris Rock in the lobby I said Chris
a heel moment that he said David no one
is gonna see them I said poor Jim he
ain't gonna make it by Monday he was the
biggest thing in show business cuz that
was after Blankman right yes I'm sitting
there going like oh no it was before
Blankman okay but no seriously I just
because my whole thing was it used to be
a running joke I said Jim if I ever win
the lotto yeah I want to give you five
million dollars to do a movie like one
character he did that would make me cry
he was a superhero he was called : man
so he pulls : out and he lasted
firefighter pound he suck him in as I
asked me bill you're going to jail maybe
like crying Jim was so crazy we'd be
like dude you got to put that on it was
too wild for a living color
yeah so that's what I just thought I
just thought that you know America was
not ready and I was completely wrong
yeah that's a good example right there
wrong being really from I thought oh
talking about those characters I'll bet
the Jim Carrey could not have gotten
away with the hyper masculine woman that
he played on yelling in color we should
know everything he's over you talking
like how was that when he went to the
gym light you know these female
bodybuilder going you know that wasn't
funny at all okay okay it was really
funny but it was funny but you know our
trans community
they deserve to live in peace and
harmony he's certainly doing some of us
love them along Jim Jim they said he
does know yeah we did a lot of stuff so
many things so wrong I was on tenth
Avenue by the way and I was right I
remember seeing a poster for Titanic I
was with somebody I'm like that's going
to bomb well I swear to God I said
nobody wants to see a movie about this
shitty boat you know it's going to bomb
well I addition for signs though I did
like a shark George yeah and I I did for
George and it was I walk into Roman it's
like hello David it's good as soon as I
hang a Jerry into my own god Terry can
act for [ __ ] this is all if I read this
book I thought the script was terrible
about anything there no [ __ ] jokes in
this I feel so bad for Jerry when you're
when you're ready okay action
hey hey George what did you do today
um nothing Terry oh I didn't really do
anything
scene that was really bad I walked up
behind it will never work
okay and Joe Cassano I got another one I
love the sympathy by the way sympathy do
you have like yeah I feel bad for a very
common yeah you're like your [ __ ] yeah
and that I did wonder the Tracey Ullman
Show same deal you know they were doing
doctor jokes is like knock knock who's
there like are you [ __ ] kidding on
this is a piece of [ __ ] and this limey
[ __ ] no never
and of course it was huge button cartoon
that was honest yeah whatever
with all the yellow people running
around watch that I like that actually
did well oh yeah which by the way mommy
bits you know big fan Tracy oh
absolutely always got a cover your hands
to him now could you don't all women
deserve their own voice there you go to
serve just as good today so absolutely
what I wish I had two tees are ready I
was I was walking through a Manhattan
day years and years ago and they would
had the bus boards up for a new TV show
that was coming out and it said that if
one family doesn't kill him the other
one will yes I'm like
this [ __ ] I know terrible I know I saw
its up and it was the suppressor and and
yeah and I the movie or the poster for
it
I imagine this hokey like oh look out
his family's after a yeah it was
presented in a completely different
light than the show Bob's going to make
you an offer you can't refuse act Lee
something like that I'm like this show
is going to bomb people hubris I think
that's right you know my dad I love The
Sopranos I was like dad when he's alive
I said dad you never watch this brings
us in good conscience I cannot watch
trifle and entertainment based on evil
subversion and corruption like you
[ __ ] let your family man see once a
year you dick on his high horse [ __ ] out
of here and when he died up rise like a
bit of good oh yeah he was he was like
Michael ooh [ __ ] are you Winston
Churchill now so he was very socially
conscious but not so much conscious of
the family's actual family his
consciousness was spotty gotcha did you
say everything you wanted too tight on
before he died several time you did in
euros I'm sick in the car yeah oh you're
just a shitty dad with what you can't
talk to me like oh yeah I was a youngest
I always said what I wanted you know we
made peace but we all have parents I
don't want to sit here for a few our but
you know the deal
we at the end of the day we made peace I
mean you have to love the person that's
there I believe that you can't change
the other person nine times out of ten
when you get the guts up to say ah you
[ __ ] me over as a child nine times out
of ten they're gonna be cold tumble yeah
no I didn't I did my best I tried to hug
you you think I tried to get you you
know that's just the way it is so I
didn't I mean at a certain point you got
to let it go or else you're just going
to be dead dude